GET A STOP AND SECURE THIS
REBOUND.
>> Joel: THERE'S SIX-SECOND
DIFFERENCE.
>> Antonio: DONOVAN MITCHELL
UNDERSTANDS THE ASSIGNMENT,
GOING TO RUN THE SHOT CLOCK DOWN
AS FAR AS HE POSSIBLY CAN BEFORE
HE GOES ONE-ON-ONE OR BRINGS
RUDY GOBERT OUT FOR PICK AND
ROLL SITUATION.
>> Joel: MITCHELL AGAINST HERB,
AND DID HE WALK?
JONAS HAS IT.
AND NOW YOU GOT TO GO.
DEVONTE' FOR WIN!
YES, A SECOND LEFT, 1.3 PUT ON
THE CLOCK AND TIME-OUT!
>> Antonio: WE TALKED ABOUT
UNDERSTANDING YOUR GUYS, RIGHT?
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE TALKED
ABOUT DEVONTE' GRAHAM'S ABILITY
TO RUN, GET SET, RAISE UP?
>> Joel: THEY STOPPED THAT CLOCK
IN A HURRY.
1.3 TO PLAY, OFFICIALLY.
WILL ADVANCE IT WITH THE
TIME-OUT.
DEVONTE' DID THIS IN CHARLOTTE
OFF THE BENCH TO THEM.
GOT A BOUNCE TO HIS GAME.
LIKES THAT MOMENT.
>> Antonio: 48 HOURS AGO AGAINST
THE WASHINGTON WIZARDS IN SAME
SPOT, KNOCKED DOWN BACK-TO-BACK
THREES JUST LIKE THIS.
IN TRANSITION, EXCELLENT
RECOGNITION BY BRANDON INGRAM TO
KNOW THIS IS WHAT DEVONTE'
GRAHAM DOES.
>> Joel: THAT WAS WALK TO BEGIN
WITH.
>> Antonio: COULD HAVE CALLED A
FOUL AS WELL.
>> Joel: FRO